everybody Joe
thanks for coming I know it's a lot
break and everyone is out the door
pretty much I really appreciate your
coming to hear a very prominent speaker
for us in the Yale mal initiative series
where at the end of year two year three
will happen just got funding for another
exciting year next year so stay tuned
for that it's been a really great couple
of years so far and I'm really thrilled
that David County FC from Toulouse has
joined us all the way from from there
from southern France it's a long journey
we've been here for a couple days a very
fruitful visit the talking professor
Harvey Weiss's seminar yesterday which
is really a master's class in how to
reconstruct climates David is a paleo
ecologist
a paleo climatologist with a PhD from
from Paris and then he did a postdoc at
one of my favorite places on the planet
Kay you live in so we have that
connection it's a wonderful place and
he's now on the director of the Ecolab
in Toulouse he's done a lot of fun a lot
of work in reconstructing climates of
the past in the Holocene all over the
place but particularly important for his
work at least caught my attention
initially because of the work at the 3.2
K a boundary the so called Bronze Age
collapse or the bronze age crisis
reconstructing climate proxy records
that might tell a richer story about
what's going on in the eastern
Mediterranean about 1200 BC or so David
a warm welcome to you and look forward
to your talk so first thing I was
strangely fighting the Jo and how they
phoned invitations so as you know I'm
French so I hope you all understand my
English okay if there is a problem can
ask question during the speech or just
after when you want so today we're going
to talk about what could be a pirate
movie but it's not a pirate movie but
it's seems ago we have invasion we have
a powerful nation in and we have major
battle between the Gaza Strip and dial
Delta
and as we know from this major battle
was located in this particular part of
the eastern mids and ran simply because
this battle was so important that the
king the Pharaoh Ramesses free engrave
is victory this battle and his victory
against this different type of tribes in
is much every temple at medinet habu so
and by engraving all this population he
refer for this population to the island
in the midst of the sea and all these
tribes are better now now since the work
of gaston Maspero and over a geologist
as sea peoples during when we only look
at the medinet habu temple we mainly
think that all these people came from
the sea so the sea peoples was a good
term for the first approach of this
oldest tribe in eastern mediterranean
but the first thing we did is we have a
lot of different information concerning
the sea peoples
the gate the main question is not who
they are because I'm not an
archaeologist so can answer who they are
but I can reconstruct using all the data
available the trajectories of the sea
peoples in eastern Mediterranean so we
made a compilation the first I think
compilations of all the trajectories of
everything was that was available as a
timer and first we have identified that
invasion is not only a sea invasion but
also inland invasion so it's a mass of
population migrating toward the Egypt
and what we can see here on this map in
that the sea people what we call the sea
people put fire to each the city the
crust and the sack each city from
pillows together before arriving in the
eastern made general just to fight
Ramses free
so we often say that Missy people put
fire to all cities and all the cities
were often left in occupied so they this
is a devastating wave of see people in
England invasion at around three hundred
two hundred years ago in the eastern
Mediterranean okay so this is what is
engraved on the wall on the MIDI net a
bhoot temple and the first question we
have in mind is the sea peoples if they
are warrior the oil why they attacked
the eastern Mediterranean and it seems
more like these people were not warrior
the probably refugees political refugees
climate refugees for a moment we don't
know but is clearly that they are depict
with wife and children so it's much more
mass migration of population to our
fertile area of Egypt than warriors and
lava Tophet attack to settle in a new
land the sea peoples are really of
importance because it's a chronological
repairer
it's the anak the Hat act of the sea
people correspond to the Late Bronze Age
crisis to the end of the Late Bronze Age
crisis so the left branch crisis it's a
period that was violent and disruptive
regard to cultures social system
practices government institution
languages ethnic entities trade route
literacy and new technologies so a lot
of different changes during the regular
screw collapsin but we know for sure
there is a social and economic and
political crisis during this period it's
also the end of long-distance trading
and cultural exchanges in the eastern
Mediterranean and from this period of
turmoil emerge people tribes that we
will all that are overwhelmed the or
eastern Mediterranean mass migration of
people
and all the eastern Mediterranean
changed from the panacea civilization to
what we call small hamlet the isolated
culture villages of the Dark Ages
so everything changed after what we call
Laban search crisis the late bronze age
collapse or whatever you want so they
clearly a big change so we are put some
picture here of different type of site
here in the back there twinning who is
very famous for this period the first
question we had mine is when and where
when we can add see people heaven and
we're in eastern meat onion so we are we
must are some evidences from our kajuk
outside because if the destroyed the
site you must at least other destruction
level a burned layer and some evidences
that show you that you have a battle in
the city and this is what we got here at
el 20 in Syria Ted 20 is a southern most
herbal town of the you get Kingdom so we
have the perfect destruction layer could
completely black you to the fire in the
area we have BrahMos Arrowhead we have
foreign wars broken pottery so clearly
there was a fight in the city at the
time during potentially the time of the
sea peoples and it's quite different in
Cyprus in the site of Pyrrha könig
kokino crema Sri coconut creme O's where
we are not a fire event but the
population that lived here just eaten
all the Treasury before leaving the town
and they never came back so white kanima
came back properly because
overpopulation occupied the area in same
thing for 1020 offer after the fire
event and after the fight in city
completely different populations
occupied the area and with a great style
pass free services replacement of
population at that time and we can they
radical bomb date on this layer to our
if possible an accurate chronology for
this and we are also a gypped because we
know that ramesses free defeat the see
people the hate year of his reign so it
could give Chronicle issue for the city
bones so first we burn start by Egypt so
if we just check the incision date of
runs as free because as we as as a as a
sane sorry grams is free defeated see
people during the half year of this
rhenium that means that the first reign
of the Ramesses freak was radical
mandate to 1187 96 or 1185 BCE so 8 year
later the see people event in Egypt the
fight the first fight which is incurved
on medinet-abu temple could be located
somewhere between 11 88 and 11 77 car
BCE
there is over possibilities if we take
into account the work of show of on
guitar is just stood over possibilities
we are apparently the same chronology
there's no major differences okay so we
know that according to this work and see
people the end of the see people event
in Egypt is around this chronological
evidence but air is not supporting
radiocarbon chronology so what we done
at tel 20 and pinnacle Caminos and also
at al-azhar take a that we are date here
we can clearly see restriction layer
where we found a lot of seeds seeds and
it's important because it's short leave
samples its annual so we have a lot of
old stones and we update of all of this
olive stone to produce weight average
date here of 2975 more or less
forever tareka burn VP and when we made
the calibration for once in Martin to
Sigma for a moment which we just keep
the 68%
when Sigma we have 1225 and 1190 count
BCE
so the see people event in Syria must be
during this period it's critical range
we did the same thing for Pinnacle
criminal 'some here is where we found
all the Treasury
Eden in soil and we have lot of seeds
differences here is wit we apply the
same technique we have date a lot of
seeds and we we obtain this weight
average date of 2960 more or less 10
radical burn BP and what Sigma
calibration if 12 10 to 11 19 car BC so
we very close because the two side are
very close geographically and here when
you just check the radical and
chronology we have very close event we
are over supporting dates from another
site in Cyprus called Alaska take a we
apply the same techniques and once again
we compute a weight average date and we
obtain 29 71 more or less 15 and when
you calibrate once again you find
exactly the same calibration okay so for
Syria and Cyprus we have a critical
range first Crone original range but we
can go further with this chronicle range
if we mixed three sides
it's just mathematic so we can mix the
free side and we obtain a data of 29 66
we have a standard deviations of 6 so it
gives for delay Bronze Age crisis only
in the northern Levant it's only in
another novel but 29 66 more or less 6
supporting that means that the see
people event in northern Levant should
be in the chromium kroner
young range of to a 12 15 11 19 car BCE
okay
and it's correspond this fact to the end
of the Kali the yogurt kingdom so it's a
first step to have an accurate
chronology but we have over data because
we work with archaeologist language
exeter exeter so we see that we can
reduce the occur the standard deviations
we are over dates over supporting date
here is not for the see people event
before the end of the panel solution
here in Cyprus docent works from man
England Ireland in vinegar and younger
and each time in the transition from the
late separate separate to see to free a
and the later I dig freebie to to free
see the respond to the same Chronicle
range so I every day every relative on
date for this event for between at least
12 10 to at least interval 19 can't BCE
so a very accurate chronological range
and when we go for deep solvent in the
southern part of the Levant in Israel we
have no date for the moment for the sea
people event of all destruction layers
but we have some red we have radical
burn chronology for the Philistine part
of the sea people it ought to be settle
but runs as free in cannon so his date
of the monochrome phase and the obtain
supporting date of 11 oh just any 194
to 11 or can BCE and most probable age
range
correspond to kill about 95 to 1140 BCE
now we have over documents to reduce
this critical scale for the moment it's
only radiocarbon data and chronicle
scale due to radio command data so we
are the Kuna for trapline from Arras
camera you Garrett we have a lot of
cranium
tablet on this side we are two main
tablets found here the first one is sent
by the great central Bay to the last
king of agar it a murabbi and we know by
this tablet that you Garrett in Syria
was still a kingdom at the onset of the
12th century BCE and we know that is
that yes there was the exaction of Bay
during septa trainer for renewal year 5
so the connect from tablet is this
cuneiform tablet must be brightened
before 11:19 BCE and establish is
located with on this tablet in a
destruction layer of you Garrett ii the
blood we found in this friction layer of
Oh Garrett its the cattle panels catechu
1.78 and it mentions tablet a Sun
Eclipse day to the day to the 21 January
one 1192 BCE so the destruction of the
city and the following kingdom must
occurred after is observe observation
because we have the observation so just
if we compare the radiocarbon data first
the brighter the historical data the
archeological data and the astronomical
data we can define the chronicle
interval for the invasion of the see
people in Cyprus and in the northern
Levant and we can say that according to
all these things the sea peoples in
Cyprus and northern event correspond to
a face a short face between 1192 and
1119 BCE we have perfect fit with all
evidences see the first thing for a
moment with an immersion we have people
migrants Ohio we don't know but we have
a radiocarbon chronology and as it's
easy to compute the calculator we ask
ourself if the sea peoples were in
Cyprus in northern Iran during this
period and
between you Garrett and eastern part of
Nye data it's around six six hundred
sixty kilometers and we are some
different dates for the sea peoples in
the later but they all fall in same
Chronicle range that means that if you
took the unting boats the speed max was
free folk notes that means approximately
five point six two seven five seven
point four two met power so from
northern Syria to the Nile Delta it will
take isn't a navigate penance for four
or five days and is it only navigated by
day it will takes eight or ten days to
be 0 so this critical issue issue the
minimum difference between these two
chronology is two years and the max
difference is 16 years so Egypt was
probably not the only goal of these
people the sac H citty from new Garrett
to Gaza it's white X probably so long to
arrive here in Egypt so now the question
we know when and where is why why
potentially we are invasion we have see
people events so lot yes there was a lot
and still is a lot of hypotheses the
first hypotheses which is now completely
abundant that it was an earthquake
storm during that phase in eastern
Mediterranean
the second part Isis was a technique
technological innovation from the bronze
to the Iran the first third hypothesis
what the changes in warfare different
type of spooning cetera and the famous
approaches is for we have no proof but
it's political struggle between center
and periphery and all these people so we
use it's not our hypothesis is
carpenters impetus is important is an
ecologist
from the 60s we first say that probably
a climate ever occur at the time and the
only problem of carpenters like there's
no proof he has no evidence of a climate
change during that time but she was
right
so we develop this idea and we call this
the 4-3 to 4.4 point to event sorry just
to make continuity with the 4.2 Levitt
so these the 3.2 event and our
hypothesis in that you have at the time
a drought event in the drought even lead
to lower harvest and this law reversed
generate famine people search for new
fretilin - just to establish so the me
great there is a mass migration but
because drought was widespread
everywhere in eastern Mediterranean when
they arrived in the new places new
country defined the same thing and this
new migrant generates comfrey
in a new in this area so this is for a
moment the hypothesis with behind the
three-point - aha VP event is just for a
moment and hypothesis so the first thing
we though we did sorry is we try to
reconstruct climate variation during
this period so we use different
techniques different models climate
models and inner is the first steps
because it's an all data but it's still
good we have made reconstruction for the
whole Eastern Madonna using different
secondses reconstruction Jericho in
Israel from Cyprus Alistair decay from
Syria doe
so to tweenie and from tear down in
Israel and what we observe
era is during the period during strong
effort from 1200 BCE to 850
BCE we have a major change in
precipitation but something also quite
important it's not present everywhere
that sometimes you have a del W she the
do you w shape heavens it means that a
drought faced a partner more wet and
then a dryer face so this is the first
approach we know that everywhere in the
eastern Mediterranean we have this
Dreyfus and premium we are at this
period that we have no data on Greece
and since then two major seconds were
published the first one is a spare
attempt from a liquid river cave where
they found exactly the same dry period
at the time and we can easily correlate
what we found
artur tweeny with what they found in
spiritum so it's once again exactly the
same event and we have a new they are a
new seconds at Maui three pack ever
still men and Grayson where the climate
where was so dry during this heaven that
there is a lattice in Sparrow time
normal water in spiritum and ear in
Lebanon a Jetta cap we found the same
they found the same event with a strong
decline of precipitation precipitation
during that period
so he took Cyprus Greece Cyprus Syria
here Lebanon and then Israel we found
everywhere the same event completely dry
for this event but the problem we are
sometimes always saying in that we want
to count if I really the temperature and
the precipitation for this haven't so we
are the new model bears on climate for
each season so we can reconstruct the a
version of climate for winter period
spring period summer period and Houghton
period its
really of importance because sometimes
in certain country like Syria you have
the maximum of rainfall amount that is
arrived in winter and here is just for
temperature but we want to see that is
erase some difference during the year
and ear is just expressed as temperature
anomaly for each period here in the
modern value here is anna-marie compared
to the modern value and we say that
during in Sparrows at Tel 20 we have a
first cold period and then a very cold
period after climate is completely
different and we can and we see that it
is not dependent of the season each
season is affected by this event is
completely very very cold
so its first time we can say that yes
the Freak that to Evans is dry period
but also very cold and so just to be
sure of our reconstruction we extract
only the winter period it's already tell
20 here for temperature winter
temperatures here for winter
precipitations we have established the
body shape here are 20 and we can
correlate the evolution of temperature
at a twinning based on parent data is
climate model based on parent data we
the keys to Greenland temperatures we
have exactly here the same shape yes but
- it's called in northern Atlantic it's
cold in Syria and we also usually so our
data are but we try to use this
population density of population in
Egypt and we see like during the period
we are decreasing population in Egypt
though so we have very cold period-- the
same cold periods that can be found in
an oven oven sorry Atlantic we won't
just
be sure to try if we can have some
correlation between our construction and
other events so here is the first phase
between the late bronze age and the
persian period area of no sediments we
have over sediment from the same area
from the late antiquity to the sub
actual to modern period and we apply
exactly the same model for climate
reconstruction temperature constriction
and you can see that if we compare with
Brighton documents that only get
freezing event in the Bosphorus and cold
winter in Istanbul we have very good
correlations so it means that our model
works very well with all Brighton
documents we are also up we also the
Sarah winter the last of the winter in
Istanbul of this period so that means
even if we have not Brighton documents
for this part we probably have the same
accuracy because this is works here it
works here and we can correlate the
first peak here is very cold dry pick we
have an average count even in northern
Atlantic so we see quite a bit later the
impact on agriculture you just to show
you first that that this Evans add in a
pattern in the future so because we have
cores at a 20 next to tell 20 in your
via River close to Ted 20 want to see if
if you can find the same evidences in
the a critical site so we take some
samples directly here in a logical site
for Chillicothe minosa
and foretell 20 it's not climate where
constructions is just Poland there if
guns but we see her during these periods
just the period between the Wright
brothers crisis and the Hurley Dark Ages
we have mainly in the site here Zurich
step some tax are like desert taxa
xerophytic neutron and most of all we
have a low-level or one mix for rest
that means that the site is completely
dry will step to develop
in institute we apply the same technique
in Cyprus and we can say that the first
pick in Cyprus is really important
we've decreased winter precipitation of
40% and the second decree hose is a W
shape once again and second decrease
correspond to 15% we apply the same
thing for winter temperature and we say
that when we have this trunk drop in
winter precipitation we have the same
thing with a strong drop of temperature
during same period
so the 3.2 Evans is cold and dry an
especially cold especially dry during
the winter time the situation was quite
different at tandem in northern Israel
we were here completely in Amman Israel
because we are in sources of the Jordan
River and you have always water in
sources and sources of the Jordan River
to reconstruct the evolution and
environment here at Tel Dan and then
what we found
simply during the period when we have an
abandonment of site when you have the
sea people event we have all this mass
migration the site was abandoned same
way and there is a heavy irrigation
system Italian an irrigation reservoir
channels and slice were simply led to
decay and what we are you know political
reconstruction is at the swamps expand
we have stagnant water everywhere around
tear down and we compare what we found
with the situation of the Hula Valley
during the know 13 14 14 and during this
period when this went expand and we have
not moving water
the malaria expanded in this place and
when you just check the inhabitants
settlement at Tel Dan after this event
there is a decrease decrease a decrease
of popular
damn and we first think that with Tara
become a moody wilderness infected by
waterborne disease mainly malaria why we
can say that simply when we work on
malaria you know that spreading of
malaria since 8000 years in Egypt and we
have lots of data in different sites
from AG but potentially we have the
Moriah
so we can study the diffusion of malaria
and we know that for new para nuclear
ocation in ten to the kinome
there is evidence of malaria the bone
necrosis in his feet so we know that
malaria was here at that period we are
saying we have genetic fingerprint of
malaria and we also know that printing
of Maya start in Canon at 1500 BCE so we
can think that probably the migration of
the disease malaria took 400 years at
least and we can say that potentially
during the 3.2 3.2 event we have malaria
around tadhana simply because who create
our situations that favor the malaria
stagnant water everywhere here is a
modern steinorth water in a site at Tel
Dan when we apply once again the same
treatment for Tel Akko Jericho is in
Israel in coastal area once again we
found the same year around the Rhine the
same event and just before this event
and we'll make the ratio of course I
start to total total sites you have a
strong increase during this period of
coastal sites and since this event we
have absolutely no data we have a blank
a complete blank
most of the site along the coast
disappear during the period so once
again could be due to the attack and
could be due to the climate who could be
due to both
for the moment so we are the competitor
we are data on populations it's always
harder to to mix the two and in Egypt
it's harder so I replace just because we
use a lot of mattress from matrix from
an Egypt in a reconstruction from the
eastern Mediterranean the the best
seconds is come from the bulrush wagon
we have clearly a decline of sages that
means that you have less input of night
water during this period in the Bironas
laggin and we have all curve from the
Karen lake but clearly it appears that
also in Egypt you have a decline
Seaworth sea water fresh water here in
the inner lower part of Egypt the
situation is clearer when you go a lake
tana near the source of the Blue Nile we
have a very dry period for that phase
and as the Blue Knight fed denial did
denial you have clearly a change in the
Nile flows during that period just to go
in Iran they also like me or because we
have once again dry his era for the same
period is four point two here is from
one to here here is a three point two we
have a strong increase of just in lake
and lake now showing that the eastern
Mediterranean was impacted by drought
but also Iran is everywhere in the
eastern Mediterranean coming to the
nearest
so we compiled all the data that we have
for is event and we produce this type of
evolution with probability to have a dry
Eastern medicine errand and during the
three point two event we have clearing a
spike we are nearly eighteen nineteen
percent of correlation of probability to
have dry event during that file during
that period so for the moment we think
that the climate will see after but we
think that the climate event is much
more good evidence of hypothesis from
the Late Bronze Age crisis than the
ovary proteases could be both hypothesis
works but this one seems to be really
demonstrated for this period no problem
once in my hand have population
migrations in over end
I have climate okay but how to produce a
causal link it's always the same problem
because it's easy to compare to make
some correlation but we don't know so I
just replace all these things no I just
change and put a cold and dry event
because it's not only a drive add milk
or advisor low harvest I mean mass
migration conflict and can we establish
a causal link and the first step we
think for establish a causal link is to
use the chronology the the question was
do we can mix the chronology we take the
course we take CP pawns give some
chronology or not the same chronology so
we use our supporting dates we add for
the onset of drew all the protein 8c 14
dates we are for the sea people in Syria
and all supporting dates we have for the
see people in Cyprus and we put
everything in matrix it appears that we
found the same chronological range that
mean that drought and civil invasions
seems to be a chronological a senior
chronicle event we cannot separate with
c14 the two events
completely goes in the same way is the
first thing the second things it when
you take a look at the connect from
tablet from this period the last connect
from tablets and from the latest from RT
and Egypt and the period between 1215
and 1195 BCE
he mentioned direct mention on the Queen
from tablet famine and severe food
shortages and staggering increase in
grain prices we have a mentioned direct
mention of year of our chip famine and
is confirmed tablet and we are or tablet
a picture of data rate deteriorating
connection in the eastern Mediterranean
and we have the first family aid ever
recorded we have an important later from
the eating King a Munda free I think he
described the terrible anger suffered by
his father in Anatolia and indirectly
mentioned drugs as a sole reason so we
are clearly a link between the climate
and what happens to the population at a
time if we go in Egypt there is also
famine event or episode in Egypt before
Ramesses prayed during the reign of run
Maranatha Maranatha so I've just
indicated the first random year's
starvation affect the population and the
Pharaoh try to earlier the famine in
Garrett by sending consignment of grains
during the Iranian Lawrence is free
there is a drop that was dropped in the
nineties charges with crop failures low
harvest starvation affect the population
annual rye oats and from ranches for to
Moran says 11
we are several episode of famine of
economic crisis it's the end of the
Egyptian Empire the collapse of national
authority the looting of the royal tombs
and it finished with a civil war in
Egypt so all during this period but men
most important things that we are here
for us it's all these Posada a funny me
because it implicated yeah it's
just that climate they have the road on
this decline
so as we have everything like this we
just compute all the project or
activities all the - what is agriculture
during this period here some things are
we use the same site in Cyprus recent
arrest suit and take a territory in
Syria tear down in Israel and telecom is
rare and we say during this underlying
period each time during this heaven you
have a strong decrease of agricultural
productivity so we can make a direct
link with main zones of food shipped of
food shortages and a reconstruction of
for impact of drought here in eastern
Mediterranean and something for the two
periods trace of other who produce
without data that we had just to say to
mention that we are the exactly the same
shape between the zone of food shortages
and the zone where we have a strong
climate impact in this area so we have
put a claim clearly a link between the
two so the sea peoples we propose and
muse the habitat tracking theory of
Harvey vice which is perfect for this
kind of things that what is angry at
medinet habu is not warriors with
migrants simply migrants with the wives
and children so his family movement a
mass migration to what fertile areas
just to have produced agriculture and
find new land to establish we propose
that migrants fleeing drought and
starvation seeking new fertile lands to
settle a potentially the rank proper
Israeli each countries across also
undermine
by climatic stress and food shortages so
we wrote that the see people samurai the
vast movement of population that lie at
the heart of change for this K period in
human society after the see people event
we are but record the dark ages
and it's approximately 300 your dark
ages we have lot of support in date for
this period for the dark ages and we
here is the example is 420 it's that
when I beaker we become sorry became a
small omelet during the Iron Age one and
everywhere here in eastern me Canyon we
found the same thing development of
rural settlements that more and we have
tetany was probably in resettle because
you have to subsistence system mainly
due to the fresh water from the river a
river advance our it's not the case for
each side so if your water you have
people even the water during the period
you have no people and site was
completely embedded and we have a rather
livable of the harbor term around 850
BCE at the end of the Dark Ages and
renew for for a future for the exchange
etc etc so just if we summarize them for
this period for us it's a cold a dry
even in Cyprus Sariah Israel and Egypt
and in some areas particulate air dam
furniture we have a spread of disease in
swampy areas and what we are compute
error calculated is that we have also a
strong decline in arbitral productivity
when we take a look at population it
correspond to a set of food shortages
starvation so generates vast movement of
population families not warriors with
families and simply when they arrive in
a new town generates conflict
give me because this town of this
country is always undermined by drought
- and if we just check the chronology we
are the first approached a chronology
for a moment we have no other chronology
so we get this one
so between 12:00 5:15 and 1190 BCE for
the city bouncing without as you see
people novel event is between 1192 and
1190 BCE
and the last the fight of ramesses free
again the see people correspond to a
parallel between eleven eighty eight to
eleven seventy seven BC teams so just
wrote that climate was probably an
element associated crisis and
consequences the decline of empire and
kingdoms of the east and following Dark
Ages and we so now it's mostly during
the Dark Ages
we fought first that the climate was
worst during the Late Bronze Age crisis
and we see now that it was worth during
the light during the Dark Ages this is
well what we have a lot of small erect
everywhere it was too cold and too dry
to produce agricultural activity and
restored exchange or in August and
Mediterranean so I will finish with by
to friends and collaborators we have
very precious muginami there is no many
thanks thank you for attention and
exactly at fifty minutes so that's
really that's room with your jet lag
amazing performance I hear we entertain
questions yet a few questions I'm gonna
start off by asking about what this
climate event is because you're the main
data you have here this w curve I mean
could it be for example a couple of
pretty big volcanic shocks because that
that W curve looks like it's too severe
cold events but not really long term but
the other part of the story is a mega
drought right it's a long term severe
drought it's not just two shocks induced
by volcanoes which would certainly
affect the Nile River flow we know but
but but elsewhere too so how do we
understand this event is it a is it a
mega drought of a couple hundred years
across met eastern Mediterranean or
further or is it can you understand it
simply as a couple of shorter term
shocks that had a knock-on effects I I'm
I'm not sure is what it was a mega
drought because when we concentrate the
precipitation we have more precipitation
in during summer and less during winter
that much more Ferguson episode a change
in seasonality it means that you have
less precipitation during winter during
the main rainy season in Syria and more
precipitation during the summer but
program that we have during summer that
we have higher evapotranspiration
so is it means that you have no more
precipitation in Syria
so it's this if the first thing is its
order for the moment to understand why
we have this change in seasonality find
during short time periods because it was
very short and maybe for the moment we
just searched for everything coming from
the northern Atlantic and try to find
link between general circulation for
climates we could be we could
potentially add the climate the volcanic
events and say yeah and it sees that we
are okay general circulation
modification meant much more and we're
sir impose volcanic activity and could
be are after to simply simple so it's in
French because here we have the two
events in the same time it's possible
Nemechek this which watch this shows and
it shows the two cold events yep this
one before
it could be it could be we must have a
cure of data we can try if we can it try
to correct our area and your data and
this time your data yeah I know that if
you give me yo that's how I can tell you
exactly yeah
a severe drought which is driven by
insulation or something yeah probably
insulation first yes but maybe because
it's bad during disparity was very cold
we have anomalies of less six degrees
could be yeah yeah it could yes it's big
big big right there's no freezin here
because ls6 is correspond to four or
five degrees during winter doc says no
crossing event but it's very cold for
Syria and maybe as we as you say that we
have two events in the same time and two
and probably mix maybe or not we will
say and giving this pattern of change in
particular shape to the curve we test
this yeah because we we use and and
that's so here show here sorry we have a
confirm tablet because this is why I
focus mainly on Ted 20 because the area
Kingdom even a lot of cuneiform tablet
from you Garrett Kingdom and we are
diverse all right here and all this
tablet is Russ camera coming from you
Jared and all this mentioned coming are
coming from you Garrett so we are
lookout proof that there is a problem
with crop productivity and Palio
agronomy during this period
yeah uh yeah
gives the four seconds I think so just
like I right here this one or not
because here you have agricultural
productivity and because we just want to
show that its first approach that when
we are these bikes is strong a crime at
haven't-- it correspond each time to
decline in agricultural productivity so
we are looking from tablets telling you
that we were lower crop in the area you
have perennial constriction showing you
that you have lower crop in your area so
for a moment everything goes in the same
way up up to see that yeah I hope yeah
we try to have the scientific data and
all the everything coming from the side
directly the hydric of data anything
mixed together we hope for a moment
seems to be very mixing together well
very well
so we can say that potentially what we
have on confirm tablet is what we have
here in the scientific data well we were
model or polymer constrictions is very
important because we have more and more
with whom what we research in in
analysis is different fighter because we
have a full moon
one factor is drought Oh code okay we
probably lot of factors and this is is a
big factor during this period because if
it was a first prayed of disease
somewhere here in Tel Dan in the Jordan
River so at this time we have no proof
problem we have we know where the the
environmental condition that favor
malaria and we have we have we know we
have to start to to try if we can
some environmental DNA says find a
fingerprint of DNA fingerprints of
malaria in our sediments so the analyzer
start for a moment we have no data we
have no results and we have a lot of
disease and we just try to implicate its
DNA seconds we have in this course and
see with if it fit or not with our
database on genetic for all the disease
and it can be very important because if
you sometimes have a disease you haven't
first the impact of climate then you
develop a judoka swamp we favor Jesus
and the people never came back simply
because you have this spreading disease
in area even if we have renew everywhere
tear down was completely abundant it is
prepared in you probably tomorrow we
have no the fingerprint for a moment I
hope with us we'll see
I really appreciated your showcasing
that generational gap between the
initial evidence or the destruction
layers of urine and then the subsequent
evidence for this in people's invasion
of religion
I was curious what you had to say about
the lack of destruction layers in
Lebanon and the Phoenicians what became
the Phoenician cities because in your
kind of your explanation for why it took
that long to see people's these northern
sea peoples yeah to make it to Egypt you
suggested that it's all a disease lying
in between you and cinnamon yeah that's
something we did but we don't have any
evidence that sea peoples that are
sacked
I mean those scenes between at least
between southern Syria and so that's the
first part of my question the second
part of my question is if you could i
hypothesize that in fact what the
Egyptians are calling sea peoples are
completely they're refugees but they're
completely unrelated refugee populations
yeah because if you look at evidence
that is actually contemporary if not
preceding the destruction of new grids
in the time to man up top so the
evidence from or for example which is
not as extensive as as Medinet Habu
it does mention Libyans and then some
unidentified people's that are later
mentioned in Ramesses the thirds
descriptions of this events you see that
there's there's almost bad towards
accumulating as many foreign ethnics
within these battles as possible in
order to showcase the extent to which it
means managing
so I was wondering whether the nature of
the evidence is in fact impacting the
interpretation in that we are
interpreting all of this as a singular
kind of migration stream right around
from the northern Mediterranean down
through that process American teenager
it was wondering if that gap in the
event is not evidence or in fact to
separate migration streams one that
impacts the Syrian population that
figure it and it stops there one which
impacts Egypt economically but not
demographically and then a second
similar events a generation later that
impacts Egypt that the Egyptians spin in
the same terms that the previous events
because all of that all of the evidence
from Egypt is coming from the themes
so I mean your average Steven is not
going to know any of this and we don't
have any evidence from then the Delta
cities a similar property and
distinguish I know for the first part of
the question and in the simple the new
questions yeah for a moment we have the
problem because I just put her part in
the ballon because it's quite
complicated in the bottom well in Israel
we are first a lot of supporting date
and they say figures tiny overs that's a
component of destruction layer from the
sea people it was first published and
then say no it's not destruction there
you are finally it's over things and
whatever you want so we have a a prime
model we are this city destroyed and
publish as district by in very busy
people during that time but when we
compute all the supporting dates and
where we are right
there's no only one wave of see people
say it's wave of see people and for a
moment because we have just computed a
cable recommendation for ter 20 it seems
like this one event and now we just is
really for the communication but if we
really denser we see at at third 20 end
like the oversight everyone estimate
Mediterranean you have different
deflagration it's not one event this is
one not one not one population in the
times this different population moving
in the Eastern male gender is at a time
and this was it for what sometimes when
we search for call
between a site and another noventa site
in southern Levant etcetera etcetera
that means nothing simply because it is
a first wave of immigration and then the
second wave and third wave and etcetera
etcetera this is why Israeli the first
dates that were published by for Israel
were completely different from the dates
that we have in the northern Lovins
simply because probably means a single
wave of migration in that area and for
the moment the main problem for Israel
for a man who suggests year his
thereafter for Israel is that the
ecologist they want to hear about the
Philistine anything like that and okay I
agree with all these archaeologists that
probably Ramesses never put the
Philistine in Canales probably they
arrived and settled here at the time but
when you check the chronology of the
Philistines in cannon even if they
settle by themself in cannon it's
completely Korea round we've all
Mississippi for heavens the utter out
scare the policy people event so once
again we need more data but the problem
is if you can be something and change
anything you published because you say
enough analysis not that oh this is a
different type of data are having han
could be could work very hard for us
concerning Lebanon's is quite different
because we worked in the balloon and we
have this event that the refuse for us
to be dated and to be studied for the
big because for our Lebanon is one
population since very long time and then
there is no invaders in Lebanon it's
much more nowadays
political than really scientific let
there is data from Lebanon we have
course from Lebanon we have a things
with ten calls from Lebanon from each
city destroyed by this wave of migration
in eastern Mediterranean but for a
moment we wait a change in government it
probably will be bit more open and we
can i hope tradition on this stuff we
have been and in ends you are right so
when i put some right this one is not
one events a lot of event yes
as soon as we want releasing pieces and
the cheeks or possibly just people's as
previous question
please features just as much context in
the center
so whenever available wondering if there
is a female client study this is this
exact same debate is effectively the
second part of the question is you say
to don't list any cultural products in
the knowledge
which protects but in order for that to
be true doesn't have to have less
rightfully so because this has been much
larger than that with me and actually
have disinfecting not only the Near East
Middle Eastern you there
what we have for a moment for two words
consent Egypt is found the same Kim's as
we found everywhere but it's quite
really quite different because Nile and
life is always 40 really bigger and even
if we say you have contraction of Nile
we talk about the contraction of the
night of thing like that you have always
flown I probably you have some branch
some small branch out to dry up
completely but it's impossible to dry on
line
so the situation whatever happens is
completely different in Egypt to the
rest of the eastern Mediterranean and
for a moment we have new court from the
Red Sea repair center and we will see
how the climate event is recorded in
coastal area to the Red Sea and it's
real important because there is no nine
inference in spot so we will see that if
Egypt was really impacted by the same
climate change
I'll ad was impacted and then we can say
we can try to imagine the value of the
nine during that period to conserve
population to maintain population where
everybody is drought everywhere
everywhere destructive in laboratory so
I think that for the case of Egypt is
quite complex
it's always complex because yeah this is
better to work in northern leaven system
it's easier than to work in Egypt and
and the problem that we all have in
Egypt except Joe for us it's a big
problem that we have notarization to
core in the Nile Tower so for the moment
we have no direct data from the 90th day
and we have try because we have a
project based on exons RIA and they are
in all cities Andrea but what is there
is a lot of mixing sediments in this
part of Egypt so we have not perfect
core we have nothing but no no climate
data we have much more you burn data how
people have removed and changed
sediments due to destinations of loss of
intermittence but not climate so her
moment I have no proof accurate answer
for that we must wait over studies and
maybe of
studies in Red Sea will give some more
data probably to do with all this
organic event and potentially climate
event we give also new data online
Darwin's after when we have all the data
we can start to apply a new model and
see the real impact of this climate or
over climate event in on Nile Delta and
on population that light lives along the
Nile Delta this is well this for what is
really important as we say just before
just to the disease because even if you
have more water sometimes it means that
we have drought you have less a
reduction of flow in the Nile Delta and
probably in a bank you have some flow of
stagnant water and you're got time
properly maybe we have more disease than
during the period we have a very rapid
flow quick flow of nya so this is why we
search for fingerprinting and I forgot
Creighton thing like that actually the
lake tana and Blue Nile 50%
Mediterranean and 50% Indian summer
monsoon so the trick I think is to get a
record from um ookay and from the ashes
core in in Pakistan to get a few points
of event for the 50 percent of the Blue
Nile flow from eating some monsoon
so we know that it's already been
diminished in the Mediterranean yeah so
now we have to get the idiom so monsoon
yeah
but a Brunei totally under chair I think
it is during three-point remembered
heavy sweater we are decreasing Oh 18
that means that waiter period during
stance if I remember and this chakra
located that does not go to three point
you know look someplace else
yeah but I think that's you know gonna
be the source of but other 50% women's
Jake just to be sure and apply your Nemo
down when we mix the two
let's see
well I just you know that corresponds in
the Delta with the abandonment of
paralysis and movement to Thomas how
there's a big event on the bluesy a
crash which Egyptological II people just
tend to say well it must've sucked it up
or something they abandon it and they
literally haul of obelisks and colossi
over to Thomas at the end of in 1180
or right after so there's a big event
something something renders here I
messed up unserviceable so something
happens with the flow something affects
the Renate inscription about the Libyan
invasion which does come along the north
and actually impacts Memphis and it's
recording both thieves and
the getting this victory column we were
not caught from from Memphis the
interesting things that the see people's
up here there but they appear more as
elements which were going on or the
identity they do come with their
particular military equipment and that
you are the Libyans with these long
swords that are not typical in Egyptian
depictions so you get this feeling that
there maybe is something going on much
much farther afield that is pushing
certain groups now they are bringing a
type of military technology with them so
that there is a really complex social
issue that the Libyans are on the move
for some reason but they're kind of
don't get on like these other groups
actually popping up during these events
interesting and of course we should talk
about Ramsey's a third we least mention
the assassination of Ramses a third wish
also from there's a flip-flop at some of
the desert sites I've worked on is a
flip-flop and the ratio of Orly to that
we suddenly get massive amounts of
Barbie being shipped on these roads
during a later onset period ready to
drop the amount of ammo yeah that means
barley is a hardy or crop it is so and
it also corresponds to changes we see
textually in prices and price so there
is something going on yeah yeah great
great wonderful comments yeah more more
to do David thank you so much for coming
giving us two very stimulating cutting
edge
talks the last couple of days thank you
for coming
[Applause]
[Music]